[Music]
[Applause]
we've talked a little bit about what
happened with the phoenix suns their
owner robert sarver uh that he was
accused of racism racism misogyny uh in
the workplace and this has gone on for a
while
he was fined 10 million dollars and he
was suspended for a year and i wondered
now you're putting pressure on the
players
and maybe minority owners do they do
something do they say something or is
the story over i'm not quite sure but it
feels like there's just enough there
that
you know can there be pressure put on
this owner to sell
the nba commissioners already
adjudicated this and commissioner silver
said all right here's my verdict here i
don't think he can go back and go you
know in second thought i'm going to do
this so i was curious what the local
reaction is dwayne rankin is joining us
and he's the arizona republic reporter
for the phoenix suns uh duane thanks for
joining us
how uh what was the initial reaction
locally when this verdict was announced
by the commissioner
well there's a couple emotions one
disappointment and that that didn't go
further than than just a fine and even
though 10 million is the max that they
can find him and then the year
suspension is like you know there's
there's a large segment of fans
there that have had issues with sorry
even before this and this just
just pushed it over the edge that hey
you know we don't want him to be the
majority owner we want him out and then
there's a completely other side that
that just like it's a he says she say
and and it's like okay well you know
there's actually a side that's actually
thinks that you know that service should
stay it's not as large as the majority
that want him out but i was surprised
that there actually is a segment of
people
who believe that he should stay but i
would say the large majority once one of
them gone and weren't satisfied with uh
the define and the suspension and
especially the people
who were who were on the other side of
those racial slurs and the in the sex
related comments inappropriate comments
but i think and i wonder
um
they're successful
the sons are successful so you don't
want to mess with something that's
successful and that you know
everything's going along pretty well and
yes he did say these things and
i don't know if he's shown remorse it
feels like he's like i don't agree with
this but i'll accept the punishment that
doesn't sound like i'm being remorseful
and that's what the commissioner tried
to sell here what
what happens now if anything with the
players uh you had a minority owner who
spoke out and said he doesn't want
robert sarver run in the suns what do
you think happens before the start of
the season
well the first thing is you want to have
media day next in a couple weeks and
then they'll the players will be
put on mode put on a spot hey what do
you think
how are you how do you feel about this
it'll be the first time that as a group
and that includes james jones monty
williams will be asked about this so
we'll get then that initial thought of
where they are last year was interesting
because when the allegations came out
you know it was like well you know we
got to focus on the season
you know it was still an investigation
and then they started winning
and then it was like it kind of got put
on the back burner a little bit yeah and
then it went 118 and all of a sudden it
wasn't that big of a story now
we know what the results of the
investigation are and so the players
will they have to hear that for the
entire season i believe at the start of
the season they will but how they
address this right up front is going to
is going to speak to how they're going
to approach it but you know basara being
away for the team for a year
is going to be outside out of mind but
the results are still there and you
can't duck those and there are going to
be people that are going to have issues
with they're going to continue to speak
out i don't think that this is going to
be the last you know the obviously the
minority owner uh was very in that
letter he was very candid
about how he felt about sorry but yeah
again he also was candid about how he
felt about sarva when the initial story
came out he said the allegations were
unacceptable so no surprise there who
else is going to speak out is who i'm
looking forward to seeing
you know what i would do duane it's i
would make him
do interviews i'd make him sit there at
games i'd make him have to answer
questions at media day i wouldn't let
him disappear
i i let him answer for all of this i
think i think the nba is actually doing
him a favor by giving him a year
suspension where he doesn't have to show
up at these games i'd love for him to
show up and have to see lebron or some
of these other players who have a
problem with him that to me would be
a better punishment than finding him 10
million dollars
what do you think well well i think that
you know their way of
this whole training thing that he's
supposed to be going through
through the suspension and his policy is
like okay well look this is your
punishment but on the flip side like you
said if he had to face these players
that have issues with him then it maybe
it would be an educational thing where
hey okay now i fully understand this you
know now now that i'm having to have a
conversation with lebron james with with
guys like that uh in an interface saying
hey a seth curry someone coming up to
him and saying hey listen you may not
understand this and and we're not giving
you a pass but this is why this is an
issue and when it's coming from outside
of your circle
of very prominent people then you may
you will take a greater listen to it and
that may be i i wouldn't see anything
you know me i would love to be sitting
in front of him right now
asking him what's going on and how and
why why we got here but but do you know
that that would be an idea do you know
him duane
well we've talked uh when i first got
here you know the team was was bad
and then they were trying to uh get
money for the renovations of the arena
so he was out there a lot you know
trying to drum up money trying to drum
up obviously the the
to get the practice facility and all
that so he needed that money so he was
out there a lot and we talked we've
talked a couple times i've interviewed
him a few times
um so so do i know him knowing no
but have i spoken with him outside of
the interview process just just small
talk yes
and and i mentioned this when the
commissioner announced his punishment
now
you put the onus on the players now
chris paul
devin booker monty williams the coach
now now it's on them if anything is
going to happen maybe players you know
from the phoenix mercury
um it's not fair to them
because this shouldn't be about them but
now it is because
if you're not satisfied what do you do
you're going to say something to
commissioner you're not going to
not going to do anything he's not going
to reverse anything he's not going to
change anything so now it comes down to
do the players do enough
that maybe forces him to sell this or is
there anything they could do where that
changes anything
that's why chris paul is so important
because he went through this
with donald sterling obviously with the
clippers so he he'll be the lead on this
whatever this team does it will be
a
chris paul monty williams james jones
huddle
and then they'll come out of that and
say this is how we're going to approach
this and then devin
booker it will be obviously a team
leader as well so he'll be obviously
involved in that but i see a three four
person team huddle going into this and
saying this is how we're going to
approach this season this is how we're
going to go about this season and then
everyone else will fall in line with
that and and but there might be a
situation where you do have a player on
the team that's like hey look man this
is how i feel i get we're a group but
this is how i feel and this is why that
the whole media day is used because
you're gonna you may be surprised it
might be a person you don't think
has
a real opinion on this
has one yeah and we're about to find out
and so i i think that's that's that's
important moving forward with this team
even last year then jay crowder was
saying that it was a cloud even with the
winning they were having he was like
this is the cloud this investigation is
a cloud on this team but we're focusing
so they were in the bunker
you know as that was going on now
it's hard to be in the bunker if you got
a bunch of people saying hey look this
is wrong this is foul what are you guys
going to do because as you say
it's on them now so there is more
pressure on them now
as opposed to last year
good to talk to you again duane thanks
for joining us
thank you sir appreciate it duane rankin
he covers the phoenix suns for the
arizona republic